well I was living out in Texas and came
out here to retire and was hit by a car
it broke and nine bones left me in a
coma for ten days and nobody filed my
disability because nobody even knew I
was it so I'm waiting to get my
disability hearings till I get that I
don't have any money
I was almost a year ago now in November
well it happened in October I woke up in
November I lost my wife I lost my mother
my dad my son and my daughter plus I was
in the Marine Corps for ten years
knowing that we were as I'm supposed to
do but it's all with me I can't live
indoors right now I was going through
really really really bad force
financially my ex-husband put me in the
ground and mentally I wasn't stable
enough to take care of my kids because I
didn't think I've had the right
technique or the right way of doing it
by myself and
hood this is not something I'm used to
I'm used to being supporter mom house
you know keep her up earned and so this
is pretty pretty rough nobody chooses
this role we we end up in the role and a
lot of us it takes time to get out and I
think that's we're all human I think
that's what people just kind of forget
in life but just because I'm homeless
doesn't mean I'm I'm a criminal or I'm
gonna I'm you know hiding from the law
or I'm hiding from somebody and I'm
gonna wreck you a lot of us are just
people that are just trying to make it
back to where we were
I've been divorced for seven years after
fifty
after a 58 year merits excuse me on the
sensitive its earlier it's okay do you
want me to stop filming no no okay
[Music]
if you still Cameron I want to my dad
and my ex-wife
I'm looking at other new future
which is really kind of tearing me up
and I'm scared
scared everybody when it comes to being
out here it kind of sucks it actually
really sucks honestly I've been stuck
I've been stuck here for like three four
five years I can't even remember the
time
honestly time just flies by when you're
out here there's a lot of dirty cops out
here there's a lot of really grimy
people out here and you know it's just a
dog-eat-dog world and the way I see it
is out here you got you got a really
fight for yourself you're out here by
yourself I mean yeah you have you can
have a group of people to support you
but when all actuality when it comes to
you tucking your hair tonight is just
you and yourself this is you yourself
you have to care yourself nobody else
I'm 34 and I've always worked like fast
food jobs so now I think that it's time
to try to make something of myself so we
we decided that we pack up and move out
to California I want to get my voice
career or my my entertainment career
going as well so we we moved out here
California is a nice warm place but it
is tough
Oh big sit done
the police for illegal lodging we see a
lot of bad things out here from our
day-to-day lives there just try not to
get arrested or robbed I lost go save my
daughter and custody battle and
anyways I don't she was worth see me so
that was really hard and you know Kyle
and I got together and
California seemed a good idea
I was taking care of my mom and we lost
everything
and after that she passed away
and my brothers passed away they
overdosed on drugs and like kind of
stressed and I asked people for change
it's
I
[Music]
I hope I get home
lost my job back when the bubble burst
in 2008 and
some back injury problems I was a unable
to work and unable to collect SSI
disability
eventually lost my place
two and a half three years ago
starting my life back
my family is Mexican and they choose not
to accept my children because they're
mixed and we've been homeless on off for
a couple years and that's what brought
us down here my biggest struggle is just
trying to get help from the resources
out in San Diego with my background with
my criminal history that was then this
is me now and I'm just trying to you
know be productive and make it in life
with my kids it encompasses so much I
mean you know where do I eat where do I
stay where do I sleep
unfortunately right now I have a shelter
than I live in but is that what I want
no I want something beyond that I want
normal to see in my life again I want
something better you know that's where
I'm at do I want an apartment yes go on
a place lay dormant art do I want to be
able to be free and experience life and
the joys and the wind and the breeze
everything that is in the water yeah I
want something better for my life
it's a blessing from God every morning I
get up such that I think God everyone
I'm now not all Christian but I have
been and I do I know without him there's
no me but I wish they believe any I
honestly do whose name them is the ones
that they're called the ones that see
somebody harmless they try to make her
more homeless the one that legalized it
I went to jail for sleeping they want me
to walk around on prop up against trees
or something like like cattle I can't do
it I'm laying now they had old man the
bike the bike a bachelors told him to
get up the old man was sick is it they
told me to get him East I can't make it
they said yeah you got to get up police
what I'm talking to get up he moved then
he died yes
he moved then he died and police didn't
have nothing to do with you damn Skippy
those people I have seen people call
owned owned them about they dog and then
the dog get took knowing that they can't
afford to get it back and then you see
that lady who called walking down the
street with that personal dog because
she was crying I said why you crying she
said God egg on my dog I said I don't
think that's real dog that dog stopped
and started crying - why why man robbed
raped killed all that you know why are
they doing it because they too got busy
scuse my language America they're too
busy messing with homeless people
I've seen a guy come down the street pee
Jenny bust a bottle and I've seen the
police pull up put the light on him and
then got out the car and walk right up
to a homeless man that was just sitting
there come on man you just saw that dude
bust that bottle and you gonna go over
there to the homeless man what could be
done to make it better what could be
done to make it better all right
the trash that's on the ground the
people that's complaining if they all
complain just come outside and pick up
one piece of trash and put it in that
trash can
dinner to make a difference stop just
stop talking about it being on beer
buddy I'm a story by doing this I'm
gonna pick up his trash right here I
didn't put that down there but I'm
picking up his trash and I'm
in the trash can by starting to help out
you know what I mean
now let me see somebody that's one
apartments they called them people that
went down the street do that I don't
think so
do you think homeless people are blamed
for the trash bin really yeah yeah most
definitely
I've seen a lady come from down their
street with a trash dump it right there
you know why she did that to make it
look like you know what it don't even
smell like urine down here I've been
here for nine years
cuz I'm a man I can't stop everybody but
most of the urine is down here is from
that bars when they get drunk they come
I hit a man in his mouth because he came
and try to pee on where I lay my head no
disrespect to me I'm a soldier I'm I'm a
father I'm a man I'm a soldier and I'm
damn surely gangster so hey I ain't
gonna take it so I hate I hit him in his
chin and there was now we best friends
every time he come down here he come see
me he was a big ass dude I don't care I
jumped up and hit him he ain't raising
but it I feel like this is planet Earth
and the homeless live on planet Boyd
Boyd is where you've been hurt and you
feel pain you understand pain that's
that's point Earth is what they living
on that fantasy world that that that
that that uh that white picket fence
that that that that dog walking you so
much man I appreciate it man time
what's your wildest dream oh I wanna
boat and sail around what's your wildest
dream finding an avenue to get my mind
back my wife this journey
is still fine
a woman really loves me and we
considerable down by then for both my
kids to go to college either become an
athlete or something some type of doctor
you know do something productive or
something go there and you get a San
Diego okay my wildest dream would be to
marry Jessica Alba no I'm just kidding
baby you know to be a voice actor in
like a Pixar movie or like a video game
I'd have my son look up at the screen
and say that's my dad my son lives with
his mom love you Dominic but to to just
have a career in entertainment some way
shape or form I don't need to be Justin
Bieber I just want to be known
my wildest dream is that Kyle gets a
part in a major sitcom right off the bat
to live in a tiny home in the last or
Alaska and/or Oregon with my labrador
retriever and I'll be happy my wildest
dream to become a family man again about
that okay can I just say that I'm bad I
just want to be a family man
that's all okay plain and simple no
everyone reaching out to the homeless
community has been something I've wanted
to do since I started my project and
it's probably been one of the most
requested topics but you guys but the
reason why it took me so long to do it
is because I didn't want it to come off
the wrong way I knew that if I were to
reach out to such a vulnerable space I
would really really have to do it the
right way and with the right intentions
because only then would it be impactful
in a positive way one of my subscribers
actually suggested the topic recently
and the comment got a lot of likes and a
lot of positive feedback from you guys
so I started to consider it again but
I'm still really hesitant because I
don't know it was just a really touchy
subject I feel like and I last thing I
want to do is make someone who's already
vulnerable feel worse than they might
already do I know a lot of my questions
are often deep and lead to I don't know
lead to like people getting emotional
and it's just I don't know it was
something that I had a hard time
[Music]
but something I had a hard time deciding
on whether if I wanted to do it or not
anyways yeah so I started to consider it
again but I was still hesitant and then
my mom said that if I were to do it the
right way maybe it would make a
difference about a lot of the
misconceptions people have about the
homeless community and when I thought of
that and I knew that I knew my
intentions were good hopefully you guys
see that as well and know that about me
I just went out the next day and I
filmed it and then after editing it I
watched it I had a lot of my close
friends and family members watch it as
well and we all decided as a group that
it would be impactful in a positive way
and that's why I decided to upload it
today
what I experienced and learned when I
went out to film this episode is
something that will stick with me
forever and I know that I haven't
perfected my craft as a filmmaker or as
a storyteller yet but I really hope I
did this topic justice and I hope that
you guys know that my intentions were
good afternoon this project I definitely
plan to give back to the homeless
community in my city more often and I
really hope that you guys do the same
with yours that's about it thank you
guys for watching and I love you all